okay so let's get started so
um so the formulation so
um most of these cars we'll talk will be
about surprise learning so in some part
we're going to talk about Express
learning but
um like I think
um maybe like 18 of the lectures will be
about uh supervised learning so this is
about supervised supervised learning
so
um let me just uh so we're gonna have
some definitions so input space
this is the data that you want to um
um classify or kind of like you want to
do regression on so and there's a label
space
that's called y
and there's a joint probability
distribution
um p over the space of x times y
um
and and there is a let me see how do I
I guess probably I will still try to do
maybe I should do this
I think this is better right so
um and
um we're gonna have some training data
points
so these are next one
y one up to extend y1 each data point is
a pile of input and output
and we're going to use n for the number
of examples in Fiverr
um so n is reserved for the number of
examples for this course and each of
these data points x i y i is assumed to
be drawn IID from this distribution P so
p is the distribution we are interested
in and we have some examples from it
so and we have some loss function
um and this loss function takes in two
labels so
and it also is a number that
characterize how different these two
labels are
and I think typically convention is that
the first one is the predicted label
and this is the true label
or this is the observed label uh and and
you assume that
this if you have
the loss is always connected
um I think in some cases the laws can be
negative but um
in most of the cases the law system
active
and
now
you have um suppose you have a
uh you can also have a predictor
because this is what you are interested
in you want to have uh or sometimes it's
called Model sometimes it's a hypothesis
we're going to use all of this in
inter-exchangeably
um all of this you know
are used in some different different
contexts but they are they all mean the
same thing it means the function you
want to look for to predict your label
so
um so this is a function that's called H
it's a mapping from y to X to y
um and you can define the laws
of the predictor
on example
X comma y
and allows will be
your first plug in h of X which is your
prediction and you have y right this is
the loss
and then after you define all of this
you can Define the so-called expected
uh or population
risk
or loss
this is kind of the the interesting
thing about machine learning like
everything everything has like two names
at least I think two is a lower bound
sometimes it means three
um
so and also like my brain is kind of
like kind of like a you for different
kind of situations I use different name
for this
um be prepared for that just because
like when I when I learned this part of
things and those literature use that
name and then if I if you learn
something else then you know like those
part of those kind of papers use a
different name but
um so so my brain just uh like this name
spurred in into my different parts of my
brain so so I might use inconsistent uh
terminologies a little bit but but all
of these are the same like they are the
same like expect it just means
population and risk just means loss
um and
but of course I will be trying to con I
will try to be consistent
um as much as possible so and this
expected you know risk of population
risk is defined to be the expectation of
the laws
and here the random variables are X and
Y
and and they are drawn from this uh
population description p and that's why
it's called population risk
and and this is your final goal
um your final goal is basically to
minimize
to find
h
that
minimized
uh the population risk
at least this is the goal for the for
the first at least
15 lectures right so like this is the
goal for surprise learning you just want
to predict expert as well as possible
okay
all right
okay so um
okay so to achieve this goal you also
have to introduce more Concepts right so
so one concept is this so-called
hypothesis
class
sometimes all hypothesis family
and you can also call it you know
predictor class predictor family model
class model family so let's call it
capital h
and this is a set of functions
from X to y
right so and
um you can Define the so-called excess
risk
because at the end of the day you're
going to search over a set of functions
right so and maybe this set of function
is very bad for example this set of
functions only contain one function
so so that's why people Define these
so-called accessories which tries to
kind of like
um
uh Define your error relative to the the
power of this hypothesis class or this
set of functions right so this
accessories with respect to
Capital H so this is defined to be uh
your population loss or population risk
minus
the best
you can find
in this family
okay so so basically this term is the
best model
um pH
which H sorry the if yes so this is uh
this is a good question so if
basically you can you ask me
I I guess so we just
for this course let's say they are
exactly the same so of course they are
not exactly the same just because
sometimes you don't have the
a unique minimizer right so you have a
sequence of like you can like a
um maybe I'll have a post to explain the
subtle differences between these two but
for almost
I think for exactly for this entire
course you can just assume if it's the
same as minimal yeah
um
cool so and this is larger than zero
because this is the minimum and so that
there's no way you can get better than
the minimum so that's why it's Louder
Than Zero
so so in some sense this is trying to
kind of to to think about excess works
is one way to kind of like
only think within the family of age
right so so now if you get zero
accessory that means that you cannot do
anything better uh within this family
right of course if you change your
family maybe you can get something else
but at least within its family there's
no way you can do better
Okay so
so this is the the basic language we are
going to work in for this entire course
um
any questions so far in any case like
just feel free to interact me at any
point you don't have to wait until I
pause you know in either the zoom
meeting or here so
um
so some quick you know examples to make
it less abstract so this is I assume
this is relatively abstract
um so one of the type of questions
regression problem
where
um your why the label set is real number
um so there are continued continuous
labels
and oftentimes for regression problem
you have the so-called Square laws
so this is the l y hat Y is equals to
maybe something about half times y
height minus y Square
um for example if you want to predict
the temperature it makes sense to use
the square loss of course there are the
difference of laws and another
possibility is classification problem
um so
in this case the Y is a discrete site
you have a set of K labels maybe it
could be two labels cat versus dog or
could be like multiple labels and
um and then your loss you know the final
loss you care about often is this
so-called
um zero one loss so basically you say
that if you didn't get the right label
then you
um you are equals to one otherwise
you're equal to zero this one is the
indicator so indicator e is one if e
happens
an indicator of E
is zero otherwise
so you'll see that you know when you
really do the Practical machine learning
algorithm you are not going to use this
loss because of the other issues but
this is the loss you care about
eventually at least this is one of the
losses you could care about eventually
this is the so-called accuracy of the
error right but when you turn it you
maybe you use cross-conscious okay
that's a that's a slightly different
question
so okay so now
um this is the setup and the goals
and now let's talk about one
uh
important algorithm which is called
empirical risk minimization
this is the algorithm
or type of algorithm that we can analyze
for quite some time
so so the algorithm is very simple so I
guess this is what you do
in practice every day so you have some
tuning laws
sometimes it's called empirical loss
and sometimes it's called empirical risk
so
so these laws we use our hat our hat
means it's empirical every time you use
a hat here it's kind of like it pretty
much means empirical
so you have the
sum of the the average of the loss on
all the examples
h i y i
from 1 to n
and then you do the so-called empirical
risk minimization ERM in progress
minimization where H hat
is you find the
the best model
in this family
I guess here I'm using argument so so
our me and if it's just exactly the same
for this course
um
so
um so you'll find the best model within
the family that's minimize your
empirical risk
and and you can break High arbitrarily
like like a this kind of like a
like we don't care about breaking times
you know in many cases and and
um so so this is the the algorithm see
using this algorithm you you may need to
use some other optimizers to find the
minimum right but this is the abstract
way of thinking of the algorithm you'll
find a minimum
and and the and the the pro the quest
key question is that how do we
um
why this this is a good algorithm right
why this is doing something sensible and
one of the the key property of this is
that
um one of the reasons why this is
somewhat meaningful is I guess as you
know already from previous classes
because
um x i y i
a ID from P so then if you look at the
expectation of the empirical loss over
the Run units of the
examples
right so if you take expectation of the
empirical loss of one example let's say
and let's say the examples are run
then this is equals to the population
right this is exactly the same as usual
x y
from p
h x
y right to verify this is just a change
of notation in some sense this is IO of
H so the expectation of the empirical
laws is the same as the
um the so basically saying that if you
take expectation of the empirical loss
our head h
which will be average of all of this
well over n times
quotation l h
right so this will be equals to L of H
and here the randomness comes from all
the X I's and Y X
right so so this is the the typical
justification we have for this kind of
algorithm because the empirical loss is
a good either in perk is the estimate
for the population loss that's why
minimizing empirical loss probably would
lead you to us minimize the population
loss
so in some sense at least a good part of
this course is to justify more formally
why this is the right thing right so
intuitively sounds right
um but formally whether this is you know
like we want to kind of prove that this
is actually the right thing and and it's
actually not that easy because it does
depend on
um
some other things for example how many
examples you have and how large your
hypothesis class uh H is
um it's not that simple
um this is just a kind of like intuition
Okay so
all right any questions so far
and and also we're gonna have I guess a
I'm assume that I assume that most of
you know this just this is just a formal
definition
[Music]
um so when you really do this you know
you have a hypothesis class when you
really do it in computer you have to
have a parameterized family so you can
optimize the parameters so you can also
have a parameterized family so you call
this age for example Something Like H
sub Theta and where Theta is in some
space of parameters
and and maybe let's say Theta is in r d
or or some kind of like is the parameter
and then for example Theta could be for
example we say that could be
um sorry so Capital Theta is the formula
of parameters
this is the
I guess you know sometimes you want to
say that you only do it for sparse
parameters or only do it for a certain
kind of elements so
um
uh and and well the example of this is
that you can take H to B for example H
Theta X which is equals to Theta
transpose X
then this is all the linear models
okay so this is easy and then you can
also do erm
for parameters
family
um so I guess here
um this is actually probably the most
important cases because in particularly
you do premature's family and now your
training loss let's define this training
loss still as our head data as L hat but
let's uh with a little abuse of notation
you say the Theta is your input of the
tuning logs right say there is the
parameter before we say the tuning loss
is a function of the model and now it's
a function of the parameter because the
model and the parameter are just
one-to-one correspondence in some sense
or maybe not one to one but they have a
correspondence so your representation
for the
for the for the model is really through
the parameter Express each parameter
corresponds to model and this is just a
I guess I'm just writing
what you're expecting probably so this
is the empirical loss and here I'm
overloading the notation a little bit
and we are going to overload this
notation in this course many times
um and uh and sometimes you write this
this thing
uh sometimes you write this as
alternatively
again with a little bit notation
abuse of notation you sometimes write
this as this
and because just because Theta is what
an X and Y I are what you care about
after you know these three things you
can complete the loss
um these are just some notations because
we are sometimes going to use this
notation sometimes we use this notation
a little bit X
um exchangeably so it's good to be aware
of that and you can Define the so-called
erm
solution which is the
argument of the empirical loss and where
Theta is in this parameter Theta Capital
Theta and sometimes you just write it
ahead
as a short time for ERM like
sometimes you're going to write this
by the way you don't have to remember
some of this kind of like uh cases just
we're going to remind you later so in
the goal as you can expect it it's
really again just to to show
the excess risk
of say the Hat erm
is small
because that's that's the success kind
of Criterion right you want to show that
you you find something ahead
and this other hand is working and
working in the sense that the excess
risk
is small
and this is kind of the basically the
goal of the first probably a few weeks
um and
and the core in some sense is really to
I guess just a kind of like a
um
a trailer in some sense the the core
idea is to show that L Theta is close to
L height Theta
right because you are minimizing the L
half data but you care about L Theta so
you have to show this to our similar in
some sense but it's not that easy
but
uh sorry this is a I guess that's it's
me sorry this is
actually I have a typo here in my nose
as well
next
okay
so the goal is to show that uh your
algorithm works right so and you know
the the this state I have er sorry they
say the hype erm it's doing something
right it's good so and what does it mean
by a model is good right a model is good
in this it means that like at least in
our definition it really only means that
the accessories is small right right if
you can make sure that you are kind of
close to getting the best model in this
family then that means you are you are
doing uh doing well so so that's why the
goal is to show that accessories is
small for this model
eventually you care about the the
learning algorithm but the but but to
show this it does depend on you know
what's the family of the hypothesis is
um but but the final final goal is that
you show a learning algorithm using
these family of models can work
you never actually evaluate uh
[Music]
so can you imagine or empirically I
guess yeah so uh yes you can evaluate
out pretty well in the sense that you
can have a holdout data so that's why
the validation data is uh is used
um
um of course there are some subtleties
about you know okay so I so how do you
evaluate the L so if you want so
um the the the the ideal scenario is
that you collect some new data
um and there are fresh data and then you
use the empirical estimator
for it
um the subtlety would be that you know
whether this you have seen this data
before right if you don't if you haven't
seen this data before then you're all
great but if you have seen this data
then it becomes tricky so that's
actually exactly what we are doing here
because
I'll have an L right so
this is kind of like intuitively very
much correct but the question is that
um this is we will talk more about this
like the the subtlety is that whether
you have seen the data before or not
um any other questions
okay cool okay sounds good
[Music]
so
and and
so and this is the kind of the main kind
of Topic in this course
um although they're gonna be a more more
subtleties before about this for example
you know like uh in the first few weeks
we want to talk about this and then
other things in this course
foreign
so we're going to talk about how to
for example one thing is how to minimize
it Theta right so suppose you know you
know that all of this grid is great but
you still don't want to know how do you
do this you know
your computational efficient way right
that's something we're going to touch on
um
for a few lectures and
um and also we're going to talk about
you know kind of like
additional complications in some sense
in deep learning in some sense this
framework becomes kind of questionable
when you do deep learning of course some
part of it still kind of survives
actually most of the part survives but
some of the if you really go into the
low level technical stuff then some of
the technical stuff stop kind of making
sense uh and
um and there are a lot of additional
complications right so until so far the
everything is still kind of okay but
that's once you go one level lower then
some of the classical techniques don't
apply to deep learning and also we are
going to talk a little bit about
Enterprise Learning which is a kind of
somewhat different but still like some
of these losses are involved of course
and energization or all of this kind of
um
um like the notorious is still like
mostly applies but with a little bit
differences
okay so that's the formulation
um and now let's move on to
like asymptotics which um
before that any questions
um
Okay cool so
[Music]
um
so what what does iOS metallic analysis
means right asymptotic analysis
so
this is a type of analysis
where you assume that
n goes to Infinity
so let's earn the number of examples
goes to Infinity
and you'll show a bond
like this of the form
something like excess risk
this is our goal which is L Theta hat
minus
Arc mean
sorry minus mean
this is less than
something like C Over N plus little one
times moreover
and here this constant C
is a constant but it's not a universal
constant it's a constant that
of course doesn't depend on n
but could depend on
uh the problem
for example dimension
right stop so
um and and a little in this kind of like
what you learn from calculus this is
like a lower term compared to one over n
um
so so this is kind of the general kind
of approach and and after we talk about
this I'll talk about you know I'll uh uh
then we're going to move on the
so-called known asymptotic approach
which I'll discuss that uh after we talk
about this so
um
Okay so
um so we closed
closed door I mean I don't know
um
could you be a requested
yeah
I think that's one probably is fun
um okay anyway
um yeah that's a that's that's a
oh that's a good question yeah so I
think um
why we care about this kind of like a
bond so we want a bond that goes to zero
as and goes to Infinity because you want
to say that if you have more and more
examples you can do better and better
um but the weather is well over square
root and all over n square that depends
on what's the truth right so
um it just turns out that
uh the right bound is well as we'll see
or you cannot get better you cannot you
shouldn't get worse in of course it
still depends on the searching a little
bit but for the setting we're going to
talk about one over eight indeed the
right part
so
who
okay so now let's get into a little more
concrete setup so concrete
so I guess we're gonna write this Theta
is RP this is our family of parameters
and Theta hat is I guess I'm writing
this again
so but just to rewrite it this is the
the ERM solution
and let's let's just for notational
convince convenience let's define Theta
star
to be the best
model
in this family right but this is the
population risk but not empirical risk
City Star is the best in terms of the
population
and
and our goal is to bond excess risk
which will be just a l Theta minus L
Theta stock
okay
excess risk
so our goal is to show our Theta minus L
sorry I will say the hats minus LLC the
star is small
so okay and I guess either
so consequence of a trivial consequence
of this is that L of theta star is the
mean
of L oxide
okay yes
so okay so here's the theorem I will
improve so I'm going to typically in
this course I'm going to take this
approach that we State the theorem first
and then talk about you know why we have
to prove it or uh how do we prove it
um
so so we
we assume the consistency
by the way this is like a as with what I
said in the beginning this part of the
uh lecture is a little bit informal
um just because I don't want to get into
too much struggling too much too too too
many dragons fragrance so what does the
consistency of failure half means so
this means that say the heart eventually
converts to Theta star
in probability as n goes to Infinity
um if you are not familiar with what
what convergence in probably I mean it
doesn't really matter that much so the
reason why you have to
have something slightly different is
because this is a random variable so the
head is a random variable right if it's
just a some
deterministic variable as a function of
n then you can Define the convergence in
the trivial way but here that is a
random variable so technically this
means
um
convergence in probability
just in case you are interested in this
but it's not that important so
convergence probably means that if you
take a limit
as n goes to Infinity we look at the
probability of
the height minus Theta star
is larger than some Epsilon
its probability will goes to zero as in
goes to Infinity for any Epsilon it's
larger than zero
but it's not very important for this
course like for this course it's perfect
fine that you just understand this
intuitively
because
[Music]
though
yeah exactly exactly
right
sorry again
sorry yeah we have all of those yes
uh yes but I think the the issue is that
it's gonna be
uh smaller vertically
so I I felt that if this is better I
think because you have more there's more
things shown on the board
um and maybe I should also repeat the
question how the zoom meeting as well
but yeah next time okay cool so
um
and also this informally you know like
uh okay sounds good so and then let's
see so
uh we also assume that
blah blah
the housing of the laws IPL star is
full rank
and what does that happen mean the
hassin is
uh I guess probably most of you have
seen heading if you have taken cs209 but
the head is just a second all derivative
but you organize it in The Matrix right
so the hiding of a function f is a
matrix and this Matrix all the answers
are
the partial derivatives
like this
and this is a matrix of Dimension P by P
if f is a function that Maps
RP to to R
okay
so
um
and there's also some other
regularity conditions
which I'm not going to even state
because
like it's uh it's probably not super
important for this course
and for example this involves some
something like this like the gradient is
finance you know um something like that
and I know these assumptions then you
have that a few things you can know a
lot of things like about the failure hat
so first thing you know that is that
um formula you have to write this so
great square root and times Theta hat
minus Theta star
this is bounded
is o p of 1. so I'm going to Define o p
of 1 in moments but this is really
roughly speaking just saying that said a
hatman Theta star
is roughly on the order of like while
we're squared
something like this so so if you
multiply Theta hydrated Star best growth
and maybe comes on order of a constant
so the what is this op offline here
again this is not super important for
the course you can if you don't think of
as constant you can just think of as all
of one as in in most of the standard CS
courses
um the details here is that bonded in
probability
as a random variable in an index by n is
op of one this is means that
means
for every Epsilon
which is larger than zero there exists
the bond and
such that
if you look at the probability that x n
is bigger than the bonds
this would goes to zero
I guess this
for soup you can think of as Max you
know if you are not familiar with the
soup
um this is going to be very small
eventually as n goes to Infinity
um but you know if you're
not familiar with all of these dragons
just to think of this as all fly you
know
um
actually minimizes unique is already
assumed when I Define this in some sense
like uh so again I'm pretty informal
here but I'm already assuming that the
minimizer is unique but indeed if the
image is unique I think you need a
hydrogen to be full rank
um but I think hygiene is full rank
doesn't mean the minimizer is unique
okay sounds good so
any other questions
so so but the most important thing the
most important thing here is that you
somehow know how far set ahead is close
to their star and and how far it is it's
kind of something like one word scrotion
um and as n goes to Infinity
and also you know that how different
uh I always say the Hat the population
risk of the minimizer to the half is
close to
the the population risk of the the best
model say the star and how different
they are so they are different
um
in this sense where if you multiply the
difference back and then you get a
constant which pretty much just saying
that L Theta hat minus L Theta star
is something like one over n
okay so and actually you know more than
this
um so you also know that what's the
distribution
of the set of hatch minus Theta star
so Theta height minus signal star is a
vector right so
um and it if we multiply by square root
n it's going to be on out of constant
but also you know what this distribution
of this random variable is as n goes to
Infinity I think this distribution is in
distribution is converging to
um a gaussian distribution which means
zero
and some covalents and these covariance
is complicated let me write it down
um
foreign
all of these are intellectual notes so
you don't necessarily have to take notes
if you don't want it anyway
like
um
um
right so
so like how to interpret these covers I
think that's kind of like a it's not
interpretable for the moment but the
point is that it's a gaussian
distribution and after scaling by square
root and so it's a so if you don't scale
backward and it's going to be smaller
and smaller
um but if you scale backwards and then
it's going to be a gaussian distribution
with a with a fixed covers
and at least means zero so say the head
is centered around to the star so that's
very good news
and also the first thing you also know
something about how different your
what's the distribution for excess risk
we have talked about the the success
rate as a random variable is another one
over square one over n here right so
this is what we have to talk about but
also you know exactly what's the
distribution so the distribution is you
know it's actually complicated States
but let's let me do it
um so you first you define random
variable let's call it
um
a gaussian random variable with some
covariance
the exact detail here also doesn't
matter that much
it's because it's come from the
derivation right you derivate you know
and you found that this is exactly the
right thing so
um but the point here is that if you
find this random variable then you can
know that
fast risk
which is L Theta hat minus l0 star if
you multiply that by 1 over n by n
then in distribution it converges to
this random variable the norm of this
random variable s is the gaussian
distribution
and you also know what's the expectation
of this if you really want
which is something like on the order for
over 2N and you also know
was the was the constant
okay so all of the all of these formulas
don't necessarily matter that much
because you know you derive it you got
this right but the point is that you
almost know everything so you know
everything about yourself the Hat you
know the description of seller hat you
know all of the Hat you know the
description of alpha hat it's very
powerful
so
um and and you can make all of these
four more if you want
any questions so far
so is that a property of what what is
yeah so I guess my understanding is the
question is that what the consistency uh
assumption was is that a property of
something right so what's what property
uh like like is this the property of the
problem yes that's that's the correct so
it's a prop it's a property of the
the problem meaning that means that it's
a property of the model parameterization
um um yeah
I have no idea
uh sorry you are not following the why
this is true
um
I guess maybe you can talk about this
offline it's okay yeah yeah just come to
me after the course yeah
um yeah but but you are not expected to
just one thing like for any anybody you
are not expect to see why this is
actually right these are just some
statements saying that okay this can be
done mathematically I'll show you
something about how to derive this at
least the somewhat informal like
um and the proof actually techniques is
pretty simple the calculation is a
little bit tricky it's a little bit
complicated you have to work through it
um but the fundamental ideas is very
simple
um
um yeah so far I'm only stating that
this is a these are all correct like you
can prove all of this and that's the
only thing I'm saying so far
and produce the sentence very strong or
are they like easily Satisfied by any
problems
yeah so for example the consistency
assumption right yes so that's a very
good question right so like so far we
see this very strong statement you know
everything about right so some things
probably should go wrong because
otherwise we'll probably solve all the
problems there's no non-linear
assumption it works for nonlinearity
right so I think the problem is that
um
um the consistency assumption is a
little bit tricky if you don't have n
goes to Infinity like like you have to
really have to have and to be really
really big then you can somewhat kind of
like have the consistency and and I
think basically the whole thing kind of
like
the whole problem of this kind of the
the limitation of this theorem is that
you need to let N goes to infinity and
you really need very very big and to
potentially see this effect
so we're going to discuss this a little
bit after uh we move on to the knowledge
methodox but the limited but yeah that's
a kind of like a a trailer yeah
so
um right so so when your light and goes
to Infinity you have super powerful
Tools in some sense
um
but still like this these are actually
reasonable characterizations for minor
cases so it's not like they are
completely off the reality I guess they
are not necessarily that applicable to
the modern practice just because in this
case we don't have n goes to Infinity
right like you have a million data
points in your image nice but your
parameters is like 10 million so so n is
not going to Infinity as you fix the
parameter so so that's going to be in
the next half of the lecture uh to some
extent
and actually when we really prove it we
are gonna you know if you do a very
formal proof you are going to prove
straight from first and then do one and
two
uh okay I think I have 15 minutes
right yeah I have 15 minutes
so
yeah okay so what I'm gonna do in the
next 15 minutes to show uh kind of
informal proof for one two
um and next time I'm going to do a
little more formal proof of three and
four and then we're gonna get done with
this asymptotics
um and then we move on to the more uh
like uh knowledge metallic stuff okay so
so this is actually the the the proof
right so the key of the proof is two
things one thing is you want to do
Taylor expansion
around hello star
and second thing is that you want to
somehow use the fact that our hat is
close to l
and nabla L hat is close to normal L hat
is the gradient the empirical grid and
number L is the population grid and this
is by law of large number
um
okay I'll elabor on this but I guess the
most important thing is really the clear
expansion right so once you can work in
the neighborhood of something then
everything becomes somewhat easy okay so
now let's talk about how to really do it
so
um when you do 10 expansion so so the
starting point is the following so you
care about the hat right so and what you
know about Center hat is that zero is
equals to number hat LL
zero is equals to uh the gradient
of the empirical loss at the half is
equal to zero this is because Theta hat
is the minimizer right if you are the
minimizer then the stationary condition
tells you that the gradient is zero
but you want to relate this to L because
everything is you know it's easier when
you do do it with L because L is the
population so if somehow uh first relate
this to
um
so you want to relate everything like
basically the whole idea is that you
want to relate to the heart to say the
star and L hat to l
so the first thing is that we try to
relate this to their stock
so you can write this as a Taylor expand
around say let's start
so so star is a reference point
um so and then you the first other term
this is the zero solar term and the
first order will be the hessing of the
empirical loss
foreign so this is the higher order kind
of like Telex like this is the tail
expansion for
um for multi-dimensional function but
it's it's a it's exactly the same as
um random showcase it's just so that um
you have to deal with some of the
matrices so maybe just a small remark
here
so what I'm doing here is that I'm tele
expanding something like gradient of g z
plus Epsilon abstractly speaking I've
not do a lot of different abstractions
in in my
um for for small things right so suppose
you care about this an Epson with your
small thing and Z is your reference
point you can show that this is the 10
expansion for this is really something
like
Z Plus number Square g z times Epsilon
and this is a matrix
and this is a the vector
and how do you verify this you can do
this for like each Dimension
simultaneous like individually and and
um and you get this equation this is
kind of like a intuitive as well right
because the the hyacin is the gradient
of the gradient so
um so so this is the the first other
tail expansion okay so now after any
questions
okay so now after do the tail expansion
then you know that this is the lifetime
side is zero uh and then you can
rearrange right so put this on the left
hand side so what you get is that
number L with a store
and then head to my sales store
is roughly equals to
minus
uh sorry this is equals to minus grid
I'll add second star
plus some high order term and then now
you have to have management start you
can take the inverse of the hessing so
you can see the height of theta star
is equals to
the inverse of the housing times
the empirical gradient at the star
plus high order terms
for the terms
okay
sorry I I that's my back it's still L
hat so far
okay
cool okay so
um and you are exactly that's exactly
the right point so now I need to
make change all the arrowheads to l
and and what I know so
I know that uh
um basically I want to kind of like
change this to IO I want to change this
to L hat to to nobler L as well and and
also I need to consider the the the the
the kind of differences between them so
how do I do that so
um I'm going to uh so at least I know a
few things right I know that
um expectation of our hearts to the star
is equals to L Theta star
I know the expectation of number L
height zero star is also equals to the
number l
start
so you assume enough regularity
conditions so that you can switch the
gradient with the expectation and you
also have something like this
so and this is equals to zero because
the
sales star is the minimizer of the L so
that's why this is zero
and this is a a p by P Matrix which is
full rack as we assume
so and
so so basically this is saying and also
you can um because this this
is
uh average
of n i ID terms right
what is the because this is one over n
times sum of number Square I'll
uh x i
why I Theta
so it's a it's a sum of ID terms then
you can use law of large number
to say that this
in convert this to
uh
this
and you also know that okay the
similarly you also know that
what I'm sorry what I'm doing here my
bad
else this is converging to
this
okay so
um
okay so if you want to just get the uh
okay and also moreover by a lot of large
number you can also get something more
more kind of like accurate about this
convergence so here you are only showing
that it's converging but also you can
know that how much difference they are
you know that if you look at the
difference between
foreign
this will be a gaussian distribution
which means zero and covariance number
LIC star
nabla
X Y first one
I guess this is because you know if you
I guess I'm using Central limit theorem
here maybe I should first review Central
limit serum
so when you have sampling material you
know that suppose
X hat is equals to 1 over n times sum of
x i
and x i are ID
from some distribution d
and x i let's say is in D dimensional
then let's say Sigma is the covariance
of x i
then
you know that as n goes to Infinity
you know hey
X hat
converges in dispute in probability to
the expectation of x
right that's the
um best law of large number that's
called Lower slash number and then the
the more accurate thing is that you can
look at the difference between X hat and
expectation facts
and you know that if you scale the
difference by scoring n then this
converges to gaussian distribution
first of all it's an order for constant
and second you know the distribution
is
um means zero and covariance X
and and in some sense this is saying
that X had intuitively I guess you know
informally this is saying that x height
minus E of x
is on the order of our square rooted
Okay so
this is Central limit theorem and what
we are doing here is that in this
equation what we're doing here is
basically applying the central limit
theorem where you apply
x i it corresponds to gradient of IO at
x i
y i
now yeah this is the gradient of the
laws and example I
okay so so basically we have done some
of these preparations so we know that
how different number L is from number L
hat is from number L and also we know
that the highest in converters and now
we can come back to this important
equation here
so and and we are kind of ready to kind
of get something real so let me
uh let me rewrite that so set aside my
favorite star this was novela
Square I always had to see the star
inverse times
you know
Theta star wait so is that right no
copy this is not
double IO Theta star hat plus high order
terms
so this one is close to normal Square L
Theta star inverse that's the first
thing we know and also we know that this
one is roughly speaking number IO zero
Star Plus some power over square rooted
right so
um
suppose you do both of this then you get
uh something like
uh
this
this is roughly equals to zero so then
you get square one over squared
um
we are asking a question first because
this takes a little bit time
uh
X hat and x o
sorry my bad wait why
oh I guess uh yes so I'm thinking X is
also drawn from d
um so maybe I should maybe maybe I
should either use x i or let's let's say
x is a generic variable that is drawn
from the same distribution d
but the expectation of X is the same as
expectations of x times
uh here right yeah okay yes yeah I'm
missing that
um
okay so maybe maybe like I'll I'll just
do this a little bit more carefully so
so I'm basically trying to kind of
replace the L height with L right so the
first thing is that this the the
gradient
uh
this I got I guess using this the this
equation maybe let's create one
so this is roughly equals to 1 over
square root n plus uh number L second
star which is zero so this is roughly
equals to power square rooted so if you
don't care too much about the the vector
versus real number of the the the the
discussion then you get more
prescription
and this one is kind of close to a
constants
inverse converges to
which is a constant so that these two
things together will give that
uh maybe I see the yellow color to
continuous minus something one over
squared and
uh on this other form of squirt so
something like maybe more explicitly you
get
let's start
inverse times R square rooted and this
is another form of square rooting so
that's how you get that set of height
meters to the star is on other form of
scripture of course this is not just to
clarify this is not exactly formal
because I'm
I'm ignoring a lot of uh things for
example
this is a vector this one over scoring
is really a vector it's not a scalar but
it's all not the order so
so that's how you get that the Hat
method starts on other form of squirting
and also heuristically if you really
care about IO Theta minus L Theta star
then you can this is the excess risk you
can also do the tele expansion you say
that this is you tell expand along the
star you get that this is l
to the store times to that minus Theta
star
so this is maybe just wait why have so
many textbooks in my notes sorry my bad
so this is a hat
um the system okay so Plus
here the interesting thing is that if
you do a first electoral expansion
you're gonna get zero so you'll have to
do second order expansion
star
times housing
plus high order service
okay so the reason why I need to do the
technological expansion is because the
first Auto expansion is zero because
this is zero so the star is the
minimizer of L
right so that's why we have to look at a
second order expansion and and if you
want to roughly see what how large the
second Ultra expansion is you can see
that each of this term this is what
we're scrolled in this is one over
square root in so so basically uh this
the the second term will be something
like one over n plus five other terms
okay so so this is a heuristic some kind
of heuristic will proved to show why
um say the Hackman starts out of one
square root and and in terms of the loss
is on the order form
and the question so far
foreign
so consistency is needed in almost every
step
I'm using the Central Central limiting
on the random variable not a functional
phrase because
uh I'm not sure whether that's
um
like
by the way I forgot to repeat the
question but anyway I remember that next
time so uh so the question was that
whether the central limit theorem is
applied to the random variable itself
I think so because x i
is the this x i right so that
corresponds to the gradient so gradient
of L and that example I is my random
variable
so so that's how I got so and then the
sum of x i
this corresponds to empirical the
empirical gradient
and
right so under the expectation
corresponds to the population grid
foreign
[Music]
yeah yeah I think yeah you need a lot of
like different kind of like regulatory
conditions to make all of this work
because for example also you
there's an implicit step that I didn't
go through which is the inverse right so
like uh I only saw that the Hudson is
converged to for example
where I did that so I only saw that
there hasn't converts the the empirical
has encouraged the population housing
you also need to show that the inverse
of the empirical has been converts to
the inverse of the population
so that's another thing
um you want to formally deal with
so
yeah every time I give this like I've
taught this like a
two or three times and every time there
are a lot of questions about this first
lecture on
I still haven't figured out a better way
to teach it but I think maybe the better
the thing is just that
like I really want to convey this convey
this idea like the idea is that you can
do third expansion you can pretty much
do a lot of heuristic stuff and all of
them can be made formal and how to
exactly make it formal it's a little bit
tricky as you know there's all great
questions right all the questions are
welcome but just just to set up the
expectation this is not mean to have a
very formal
um derivation here
okay so I think that's uh that's all for
today so
um next time we're gonna make this a
little bit formal Maybe for 15 minutes
and then we can move on to other things